this program is brought to you by Emory
University the following is in
celebration of Emery's 175th anniversary
brought to you by Emory report hello I'm
Gary Hawk and this is an emory history
minute in 1984 emory university
presented a challenge to the renowned
atlanta architect John Portman triple
the size of the alumni memorial
university center the a mock as it was
called without changing any of its
classically designed exterior marble
walls Portman rose to the challenge
famous for designing atrium hotels he
incorporated the rear facade of the a
mock into an atrium the resulting space
was called the coca-cola Commons this
elegant wall was constructed in 1927 as
the entrance to a small auditorium and
dining hall dedicated in 1985 and named
in honor of Emory alumnus r Howard Dobbs
the new building is called the Dobbs
university center call it the duck for
short the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University